I read this recently and I believe it
but I don't know how you feel about it
that Basic Instinct is the most passe
has the most paused moment in movie
history
in all of movie history it is the most
coveted what what moment would that be
it's done yes it's actually the credits
people really want to know who the
cinematographers know but it's such a
it's it's that's all of movie history
thousands and thousands of thousands of
movie you have that moment that's just
incredible I'm popular too yes you are
you get recognized what we have a photo
here of a young fan that recognized you
and I have to ask you this actually
happened on the street tell us the story
that happened behind this he was across
the street and he looked at me he was so
stunned and I thought oh okay and then
he walked over you guys this is gonna
seem very creepy but he didn't even
expect to run into you he was just
walking around wearing that shirt
in Israel in Israel I'm he's
hallucinating yeah and I was like we
have to take a picture in this case I
think yes we have to take it I think so
you okay you get pursued by a lot of
young men a lot of young men pursue you
it's like baking pies is it really okay
is that truly what you find that young
men are just good for pie
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this isn't me doing this I'm asking
legitimate questions this is all your
doing I tell you right now I've heard
that and you prefer is it's true you
would you prefer a foreign men to
American men these are legitimate
questions do you have someone to propose
why I don't know if you know this but I
am of Spanish descent yeah my name is
Fernando by your swarthy to me for the
complexion
yeah I am the whitest man to ever live
you are kind of a snakes underbelly
thanks a lot I think that was meant with
love yeah
we're Irish it's really pathetic we were
talking about yeah you're Irish but
you're carrying it off you have you can
tan your iris but you can't end yes I
look like the first pancake off the
griddle I've just got like freckles and
spots everywhere you you have an
absolutely beautiful complexion I stop
it okay but seriously I have I it is
that quite if you're pale I'm a very
pale Matt and this is what you're seeing
right now is with this is seven hours of
makeup posed they get a hose that paints
a car and just fire it at my face so
you're actually getting the the nice
treatment of the of the Celtic land are
you from which what do you mean the part
where they're depressed and they drink
I'm praise they're another part
I'm from the potato famine yeah let's do
yeah we came what we came over before
actually just before the Civil War we
came over mm-hmm and they said one day
if we work really hard one of our
descendants will be on TV and make an
ass of himself and look it's happened to
two of us no you're doing fine